[Music]
[Music]
okay i think we are live uh welcome
everybody to juliacon 2022
it's a very exciting conference and
i'm pretty excited to be
uh presenting the first workshop the
first pre-conference workshop it's an
introduction to julia language for
very very beginners and newcomers
it's very accessible
first of all let me present myself
i am uh jose estoropoli i'm originally
from brazil and i live here in in brazil
and oh we do have a lot of comments okay
welcome everybody uh
yeah nice good morning from calgary okay
good morning from sao paulo brazil
uh actually good afternoon
sort of here so
uh
i'm uh associated professor here at in
in brazil at a university called uni
and i also work at kumas ai which is a
julia based
pharma company
and i'm also one of the authors of this
nice book here it's free
uh open access available in three
languages
uh
i'm gonna
show
a little bit it's free for you to use we
have english chinese and portuguese
translations
all translations were done by volunteers
so that's pretty exciting
so today we are we are going to do a
three-hour workshop introduction to
julia
we are going to have five minute breaks
and i need to hide this thing okay
and we are going to do a five minute
breaks
every 45 minutes
so at uh 10 45
those who are in the eastern
new york uh florida time zone
or uh in 45 minutes we are going to do a
five minute break
and we are going to keep doing that
until we hit the three hour mark that's
how
um
we
are doing it
uh okay good morning 12 am from sydney
okay uh good morning viraj welcome to
2.com
so
first of all
uh
let me just
share my screen i'm going to share
so
i think uh
i think you guys are seeing this
today we are going to be using an ide
that's integrated development
environment
which is called a vs code it's one of
the most popular ones that you can use
uh while you are doing a julia
programming and doing uh july stuff
first of all why should you use uh julia
i have some opinions it's my opinion so
i don't know if
if everyone else agrees with me but i'm
going to
disclose them right now it is fast
it is very fast
that's one of the catching points of
julian
uh the third thing is that you don't
need a
dc plus plus for trend or any other what
we call a slow productivity or
a language is that that you you need to
compile and it's really difficult for
you to prototype
this is something that we in the
community calls the true language
problem so you prototype something in an
easy but it's a
slow language
and once it works you need to implement
in a fast and hard language
so that's what we call with the two
language problem
it has a friendly syntax uh those
those of you coming from matlab or
python you'll be very familiar with the
syntax we'll
go we'll go really easy today
it's very accessible
it's very easy to install you don't need
a c plus plus two chain or
a compiler like other programming
languages
that you need to install a lot of stuff
and it's very complicated especially if
you're using windows
one nice thing is that we can do unicode
characters and we can do our favorite
latex so no more alpha and beta hello to
this alpha and this beta so this is
something that i love it because you see
an algorithm in a textbook and it's a
one-to-one translation to julia code and
this is really nice as i said it's
really easy for you to add new stuff to
prototype new algorithms in that are
that are straight from the gun is
straight from the get-go really fast
and lastly uh this is one of the also
selling points of julian
project management and
making uh reproducible environments is
really easy they are baked into the
language into the standard library so so
every install of julia will have
uh
by default
all that you need to do project
management and
uh reproducible environment so you don't
need to mess around with 30 30 party
solutions
or to
on board or teach your collaborators how
to
have a
reproducible environment how to have the
same environment as you do when you are
coding with them in a collaborative
fashion
we do have one question here
uh
so we have this this uh
someone is is asking is it from the
basics yes it's from the basics our
target audience is
people do who have not
even seen
one single line of code in julia
we assume that you have a basic
knowledge of
programming
that you either
knows a little bit of
python r or matlab
and because some concepts
we assume that you are familiar like the
concept of types variables but it is
from the
really really basics
that's it
uh
so
as we go into the uh
real basics
let me share another screen one second
so
so how do i install julia you go to the
julialink.org website
and there is
the first stop banner it's download but
it it says download you click on that
and you get into the downloads
page
and always go for the stable release if
you need something else you can go by
you can go to the long term release but
generally for like daily usage
uh your stable release is fine it's from
may 6
2022 uh and here you can pretty much
uh go into your your platform so if you
are windows user you have a 64-bit
installer here it's an
exe so it will install julia for you if
you are in a mac
you need to download the dmg file it
will install julia for you and if you
run linux either x86 or arm architecture
you also will have
binaries here for you to download if you
are using g libsy or muscle
uh
systems if you don't know what that uh
that means don't worry
and of course if you are a true hardcore
user you can always get the source code
and compile it
yourself
uh but it's really easy to install you
just go
into joolaling.org
and
uh hit downloads button and choose your
platform and you pretty much either get
a binary like a
a file that you can execute and it will
be
julia for you or you can pretty much get
an installer like a
windows.exe or a mac dot dmg file
so we got uh one question
uh
yes we are going to get a little bit
into how to add packages
uh and
we
but but we are not going to go in depth
into that
but we are going to
definitely talk a little bit about how
to add packages and with packages how to
activate an environment
okay let's see if we have questions in
the
pigeonholed
uh
i don't think we have
uh
questions so far
uh okay um
let's let's move on so
today's uh workshop it's in this uh
github here
i don't know if i if i post it here you
will see it
okay
uh
yeah there we go uh i posted to every
channel so youtube facebook twitter uh
and linkedin you should receive this so
this is a public repo
as you as you can see there is nothing
here
it's just like a boilerplate code
because i'm going to be doing live code
but after
our session our workshop i will commit
those changes into the into that
repository and you can also visit that
later for the full code that we typed in
today
so let me stop sharing
again and go to
ps code
so
if you go to the
repo that i just sent you you'll see
that we have nine files they are
numbered form from zero one to zero nine
uh julia uses an extension called jl so
every file that ends with jl it's a
julia file
and if you install
the
julia
language extension so if you're going
into your extensions
in vs code you will find uh julia
and you can pretty much click on that
and install
it's it has around
15 000 downloads
and this is the extension if it has less
than one thousand dollars you are
probably in the wrong extension
so that's how you do it you click on
install it will install by default
and it will bind to every uh packaging
sorry every file that has
the dot jl extension uh if you open that
file in vs code
it will by default um
run the julia extension
so that's the idea
so
let's open the file one
it's called packages
and we are going to showcase
how to add packages how to remove
packages
and
how to add any specific version
what are those things called projectomeo
and manifest crumbling called the tamil
files
how to update your packages and how to
clean your outdated or unused packages
because if you keep adding a lot of
packages sooner or later
you will
probably run out of
disk space so it's it's a common
habit to always clean out date or unused
packages
so
um let me just open a new repo
i can go here in this gear icon manage i
go to the command palette
and i have julia reppo
so
[Music]
where is julia
i think it's rebel
uh yeah it's this one julia start repo
or you can go in the keybinds that
this shortcut has so it for me it's out
j out o but for you might be another
thing maybe if you're in a mac or a
linux or windows
it's different so i'm going to start a
repo here let me
put that down here
we have a little bit of space
here is a jeweler apple
and as you can see
i can type in the repo if i want to
i can
and if i do something like
let's do
float and i hit tab
a couple of times it will auto complete
for me so we do have auto completion
there is also a nice workshop from
miguel
and
which will cover uh julia's repo mastery
i think it's on friday maybe so check
julia con's
check julia cohn's
[Music]
schedule
so first of all how do i use packages
we do have some packages that comes with
julia these are the standard library
modules what we call
uh let me showcase
i'm a statistician so let me showcase
the
uh standard library is statistics module
so
i load the packages
with the using statement so julia has a
using statement it's pretty similar to
the
import
from python or from r it's the
library
function
so these are similar
and
julia we generally use the using
statement so i'm going to use the
statistics
as you can see there is a small tooltip
here
uh
telling us that the statistics is a
standard library module for basics uh
stats functionality so
i hit i i pretty much hit the
autocomplete
and now there is one nice thing in vs
code we have some keybinds to send
the line
which we are
currently in to our terminal
you can do either control enter so this
sends this line here so i pretty much
hit ctrl enter and the line was executed
in the repo
if you want to
execute the line and move forward
you do it uh shift enter
so shift enter will
execute the line and move forward
and it movement forward because
uh
in julia
it's similar to r and python uh the
hashtags there are comments
so
that's why uh pretty much it went to the
end of the file because we don't have
anything else we just have comments
so that that's the idea here that's how
we we import packages into our
environment
but to get these packages imported we
need to install them
how do we add packages
to our
environment
so we go to the repo
and i'm going to type
the open break the right bracket
when i do that
you will see that the repo will change
color and it's not going to showcase a
julia
it's going to showcase a pkg
that's short for package so if i hit the
left bracket
you see that
it has changed
to
pkg
and also the color has changed from
green to blue
we are in the 1.7
uh
environment this is my default
environment because i'm using a julia
1.7
version
and we can pretty much do a help here it
will showcase some
commands that we can
uh
we can
type in this special
blue repo
so
as you can see the one that we are
looking it's called the add
and we also have the
remove or rm
and we also have a nice one called
status or st
so for example suppose i want to add a
package called
i don't know let's see a package that's
not going to
okay benchmark tools
so
if i do that
it will add benchmarks to benchmark
tools package into my environment it's
going to do a little bit updating
and as you can see
benchmark tools has been added to the
project tamil
we also have something that was added to
the manifestomer we'll cover that in a
moment
and if we do the
status
you see that we have now five packages i
i already had those uh three packages
and i added the benchmark tools but i
can also remove packages so let's remove
the pluto
so i can do remove pluto that will
remove the package from my environment
and it removed pluto from my project
tomorrow it also did some changes in the
manifesto i'm going to speak a little
bit about manifest files in a bit
uh
and
if you go into the st or status i'm a
lazy guy so i'll be pretty much
typing the
the least amount of letters that i need
to do but you can also do status so st
you see that pluto has disappeared so we
don't have pluto anymore in our
environment
so that's how we add
and remove packages
and since we have
uh
benchmark tools in our environment we
can import
it with a using statement so i can do
using benchmark tools and vs code that
is the the name of the ide that we are
using uh vs code already detected that
we change it some things in our project
environment in our current environment
and it also
uh detect that and it's suggesting as an
autocomplete
uh we want do you want to import
benchmark tools yes we do so we pretty
much hit enter and if we send this line
with ctrl enter to the repo
you'll see that
now we have benchmark tools and
benchmark tools has some nice
macros which we are not going to cover
right now one of those is at b time
that's benchmark time and as you can see
it's pretty much uh
it's pretty much here
so we so we successfully imported and
added and also uh
uh removed a package from our
environment
so that's how we add and remove packages
we can also do
adding an specific version
how do we do that
so let me just go back to our uh
pkg shell that's what we call it it's a
right bracket
so it's this icon here i type it my repo
has turned blue and the julia prompt has
changed to pkg
and if i do status you see that
benchmark tools is version 1.31
suppose i don't want that function that
that version i want the version 1.2 i
can do that with add
benchmark tools and i hit tab to
autocomplete
i use the add symbol
1.2.0
that's how i add
a specific version of of a package
i do that
and as you can see it's installing
benchmark tools it's updating and
this is a nice prompt here saying that
our project tamil
has been
uh
updated
actually has been downgraded benchmark
tools was downgraded from version 1 31
to version 1.2
and to install another version
we can pretty much do the same thing
benchmark tools and i hit tab to
autocomplete so one three one and you
see that the prompt will be in another
color with the arrow up
uh meaning that we updated our benchmark
tools
installation in our environment
uh to version from version 1.2 to
version 131
so
uh that's pretty much how we we add
and remove packets let me see if you
have any questions in the
pigeonhole
does july have an imperative numerix
library like pandas i love bundles but
i'm
actually aware of heavy python overload
of big data yes we do we have a package
called
data frames which is a much nice nicer
name than than founders i i think
uh it's it is much more intuitive data
frames
and it does everything that bundes does
but faster and easier there's going to
be a workshop by one of the lead
developers of the data frames package
uh it's
kaminsky i don't know when so check the
uh joola link i think it's on saturday
but i might be wrong so check the julia
cones uh
uh schedule and don't miss that workshop
it's uh one of the greatest workshop
from data frames by the
man himself the one who
develops the main developer of data
frames
let me see another question the name of
the ide is visual studio code vs code
it's easy to switch from python or r to
julia yes it is are those language
similar yes it is
uh they have a similar syntax actually
uh
joule is
more similar to python than r but
uh it's it's easier to switch from
python to julia because the syntax is
very similar
i don't see any more questions here
and
okay that's it let's continue now
i said that i was so
i was going to um
tell you what's the difference between a
project tomorrow and a manifesto so
i'm going to to show to you what a
manifesto looks like so
uh i'm going to do a help status because
i always forget the comp the
which are the options
i have a bad memory
um
so okay there you go i want to do status
of my manifest so
that is with the flag m or the long flag
uh
oh
uh
[Music]
gpu
and pretty much those three uh gpu stuff
dependencies in my manifesto they were
included because i did in my uh
project tomorrow i did something like
add buddha when i did add cuda it
already imported all of the dependencies
and stick it into a manifesto
so the manifesto is machine generated
and it has all the blueprint of your
packages and your dependencies so if you
want a 100
uh reproducible environment you pretty
much send your code to your collaborator
you send your project tamil along with
your manifesto and that guarantees a
hundred percent that they will have the
same environment as you do the same
package versions and everything so the
code will be will run the same in both
computers in both environments so that's
one nice thing about julia and
it's
right
into the default store of julia you
don't need to store anything to use the
pkg
[Music]
options
so that's how we do it
and to get back to the julia wrapper we
just hit backspace so
i can i just hit backspace i mean the
pcg i hit backspace it to go back to the
junior repo
also please uh the
we do have chats for facebook linkedin
uh twitch
and youtube so
i cannot keep up with all of those
uh but i'm focusing all of my attention
into the pigeonhole so please
uh
send your
questions into the pigeonhole
uh
are we having uh audio issues can you
guys hear me okay
oh and
okay so it's the internet refresh your
streams
uh okay
so i guess it's not on my side i'm in a
cable connection so i pretty much
know that
uh
i have a pretty stable internet so let's
let's hope
okay let's see one more question in
pigeonhole
um and please anyone from the julia
community
uh and julia fox post the pigeonhole uh
i think it's in the is in the video the
description also but uh post the
questions in the pigeonhole
post the link to the pigeonhole please
okay so we have some uh advanced
questions that i'm not going to cover
here
uh
because this is a introduction but uh
there is the uh if you want you can go
to the documentation
to the
uh pcg documentation so just type in
pkg.jl in your favorite uh web search
and you pretty much will land into the
julia standard library module pkg where
you see all the documentation all of the
user case
and pretty much all your advanced
questions about project management in
julia between the different versions
will be
solved
or answered or pretty much
due
in the documentation so
let's move how do we update packages uh
if we go to the
help again in our pkg mode you see that
we have an update
so i can do pretty much up
i can choose a package so
i can do up um
let's see
maybe cuda
uh that's a package that i have and it's
updating cuda as you see uh
i i had a minor release
that was updated from 311 to 312 and
it's pre-compiling all of my all of my
my my packages
and
uh
that's pretty much how i do how i update
if you want to update all of your
packages you do just up without
any packages so
yeah i shouldn't have updated code it
takes a while to compile
okay so if i do just up it will try to
update all of the packages here so as
you can see julia promoter needs
updating so that's pretty much how i
update stuff
uh the last things so how
do i clean up
so if i go to the
help again suppose i have some outdated
do you guys remember that i remove it
the pluto
package i did a remove pluto so if you
see my
status in the project combo i don't have
pluto package here i had a pluto package
i remove it
so
if i go into help again you see that we
have a
gc a gc command this command will
garbage collect that's why it's called
gc garbage collector
uh it will garbage collect all of the
packages that you are not using so if i
do gc
it uh delivered no packages but i can
force it if i do help gc
you see that i have all
so
i can force it i can say okay i want to
garbage collect all of those and
if i do that you see that i deleted six
packages and i release it 15 megabytes
of disk space
so
there are folks that have like gigabytes
of unused packages so if you do gc dash
dash all
uh
you pretty much have like free
uh
i don't know how
how many gigs of uh storage
claim it back so it's a good practice to
always do
weekly or monthly igc
uh dash dash all in your
in a fresh julia repo session
so that's how we do it uh let's move now
to the variables
uh part of things now i'm going to start
doing a live coding so let me take this
out here
let me
shift things around
so let me see if we have some new
questions
uh
cuda is to be used with nvidia right are
there any alternatives for mac m1 users
yes there is it's brand new it's still
in development it's still like
a beta testing but you can try it it's
called
metal.jl
uh just go to the julia gpu.org i think
it's julia gpu.org
and
the latest blog post i think it was from
last month
uh
ting bezard which is one of the
developers of the whole uh gpu ecosystem
he just announced that you you can try
it out doing uh
gpu computations in
uh apple m1 m1 silicon so i think the
package is called
um
i think the package is called metal.jl
but
check check that out also i think bazaar
will be doing a workshop i don't know
when check the julia cone schedule on
how to do gpu computing in julia so if
you have a gpu and you want to do
nice stuff in the gpu using julia to
make julia even more fast
you definitely would check out that
uh workshop
uh
oh that's a great question uh the code
does not echo to my terminal just the
result yes it's because i i went into my
settings and i changed uh something so
if you go into your extensions tab here
and you click on your julia language and
you click on extension settings
let me take this
out of here oh okay
uh and you go down here uh
there you go uh execution coaching repo
so you pretty much uh plug this as on so
then your code will be executed and show
in the repo i like this because it's
more verbose
i prefer to always know what's going on
in my repo
and also i change these execution type
to both but this is the default but the
thing that i change is this julia
execution coding repo and
hit the option box
uh so then you have the same experience
as i do
and this is the only thing that i change
in in in julia
in my in my settings
let's close this
let me see if i have more questions here
okay let's let's move on uh i don't see
more questions here so
um
let's move on uh let's talk about
variables so in programming we have uh
typical variables and these variables
have a certain type
uh
i'm just going to cover the basics one
these are integers real numbers
booleans
and strings
so
let's say i have a variable called
x
and i i assign this x with the equal
statement a value
3.3.14
so
and i hit ctrl enter to send this to the
repo
and
this is how i do
oh this is not integer sorry this is
real numbers so this is how i do um
real numbers in julia
and
i have some helper functions so if i do
type off
let's do in the
code here if i do type of x
and i hit ctrl enter
as you can see uh our variable x which
is a real number has the type float 64
and float 64 means it's a float
of a floating point number
uh with precision of 64 bits
uh and this is pretty
pretty much the standard in nowadays
systems so every system most of the
systems is 64 bits
and
that's how
we define real numbers in junior they
have the type load and the precision
most of the time they will be 64 bits
integers let's say i have an
variable called y
and this variable is 10
or or even better 22. so welcome to
julicone 22.
so if i do this
you see that uh it's it assigns 22 to
as the value of a variable y and if i do
type of y
you see it's a inc 64
and that's a
an integer with precision 64 bits so
that's
our float and our uh
uh
real numbers uh these are the
most
uh used uh types
numerical types in julia the integers
and the floats both of them with 64 bits
of precision
we also have the booleans like every
other language so
a boolean is a binary variable something
is either true or false that's a boolean
algebra
and we can assign i don't know uh let's
let's get a little creative so mortality
i think that mortality for everyone it's
a true statement so everyone is mortal
so i can pretty much do mortality equals
true and if i do type of mortality
you'll see that it returns that it's a
bullion
it's a boolean type so the bull type in
julian
it's
uh
boolean variables true or false
and you can see that
there is a certain pattern emerging here
so
some things in julia are like title case
so you saw the bench you saw the the the
bench
mark tools package so this package is
a title case so benchmark has a
capital b and tools has a a capital p
also the other one that i told it's
going to have a
a separate workshop just for that
package it's data frames
so data frames we have a title case
and the types as you can see in 64
float64 boo
so
there's a convention in julia
that
packages
modules and types they are title case
so that's why
bow
it's title case
uh float 64 is title case and
in 64 is title case and packages are
title case and also the standard library
modules like statistics
are title case
uh this is a convention julia everything
else is
lowercase
so that's why i'm using mortality as
lowercase not doing something like this
that is a nice convention that most of
julia users and developers they
assign to
so
that's why there are some things that
are title case some things that are not
so rule of thumb
package modules and types they are title
case
let's talk about our last type of today
we do have way more types but i'm just
gonna cover the basics
strings
so i string in julia
let's say
let's not do julia let's do my string
okay my string
so welcome to juliacon
in julia strings are is a
is
represented by a string of characters
wrapped around double quotes so if i do
this
and i do
type of
my string
you'll see that this is a string and of
course it's a type so it's title case
uh now there is one
uh caveat here one distinction from
other languages so in other languages
notorious notoriously python
you can do my string 2 you can do
single quotes you can do something uh
welcome to julia
and as you can see ps code is already
warning me that that this is this will
error but let's run this line of code
and
you get an error and a stack trace
called syntax it's a syntax error
character literal contains multiple
characters that's because julia makes
the distinction between strings and
characters
strings
you use double quotes
characters single
character
types you use single quotes so
uh
we cannot use single quotes for strings
just for characters so i can do
something like
uh my chart c
and as you can see if i do type of my
jar
you get back this is a chart type so
single quotes in julia are reserved only
for
uh char types so
only um
single
character so
strings you must use double quotes
that's one difference from python so you
cannot use
you you cannot exchange
interleave
double quotes with single quotes
so let's see we have some questions in
the pigeonhole
can a single character be utf or unicode
yes
you can do something like
my unicode share i think yes let's
otherwise i'll get
a very naive error
live so let's see
uh let's do
alpha
oh no we cannot do it
let's try to see if i can do this uh yes
you can do it so
uh type off
so let's grab
typo
my unicode char
and it's a chart there you go we can do
it uh unicode and
also uh to piggyback on that question
how do i type unicode characters so if
you're familiar with with latex
you pretty much do it like in latex you
do it forward slash and the latex
command so if you want like capital
omega
you can do omega and you see that you
have a small two tip here
and
for completion and if you choose the
first omega this will translate to our
omega capital omega we can also do with
lowercase omega so this is omega there
you go we have lowercase omega let me
take my mouse out we can also do i don't
know
we can also do um
pi
and pi
uh we can do forward slash pi and then
we hit tab
and pi is nice because that is a
constant so it's
so
defining
julia as you can see we do have some
constants like like pi and euler
for a back backslash euler and you hit
tab you get the euler constant so e
as everyone knows so that's one nice
thing about julia one to one math uh
translation from code from textbook to
code of or from paper to code that's
really nice
so let me see another question here
uh what is the use of character apart
from string uh they use is mostly for
performance so sometimes you are going
to be using characters and it's going to
be faster so julia everything is all
about performance
so
that's why
we have different types for character
and for strings
mostly for performance
issues not issues for performance
motifs
what about using quotation inside a
string
i think you can do that
but i have another experiment with that
so try it out and if it errors you can
go to our discourse and ask a question
there
our community is very receptive
and
you'll be uh
welcoming yourself into the community
which is a
one way to get uh more acquainted well
to a a new language like julia
so let's move on i already covered type
of
now there is one nice function called
methods with julian it's uh loaded it's
already available when you load a fresh
julia session
and sometimes i get like a type and i
and i say okay what is this type i
what can i do with this diet what
functions can i
uh what
which functions accept this type as an
argument
so which functions can i use with this
type
uh this is a nice function called
methods with uh it took me a while to
find that out so i always think it's uh
it's a
uh great to uh tell beginners because
you can empower them
so let's do
methods with
and
so if i hover
in a methods with
why you are not
showing the help
okay let's try
let's try again okay
methods
so
okay so if you hover over it should show
like uh help for for this but if you
want to
know more about a function or know more
about anything in julia you can go to
your repo type the question mark so if i
type the question mark uh it will change
my repo from green to yellow and also it
will change the prompt from julia to
help so this is my help repo my help
terminal
so here
autocomplete also works so i can draw
methods
with and then hit tab to autocomplete
so if i do that and this is the last the
last thing then we go into a five minute
break
as you can see
this is the function signature uh so it
takes a pipe a mojo or a function
and returns an array of methods with an
argument of type t
so i pretty much call that function
the first argument
it's the
type so let's see what i can do with the
string type so if i do methods with
string and i hit ctrl enter to send
this code to the repo uh it's going to
be pretty crowded here because we have
128 functions that can take string so
i can do something like
a
match
so match function
to to doing like uh regular expressions
matching i can
i can i can use it with string types i
can also do print
we are going to cover this after the
break i can also do a repeat i can do
starts with
uh transcode i can do try parts you have
a lot of um
a lot of
you you can't have 128 functions in your
environment that can take
a string
as a type in one of the arguments so
that's how you do it uh that's that's a
basic introduction to typed into the
variables
so let's uh
do a five minute break we'll be back in
five minutes i'm gonna set a timer here
do i set the timer
there you go see you guys in five
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so uh i got us some couple more
questions before we
uh
resume
ops engineering how do you see julia
growing into that space i'm not going to
give my opinion but i'm going to invite
you to go to anthony's browns
workshop and i i might have
mispronounced his name so
uh workshop on machine learning with
julia and ask him that that that
question uh he will be much more um
uh he will give give a better
uh answer than than than than miss
certainly because he is
in that
ecosystem
so
[Music]
another question about uh our july
packages on atom editor is still
supported
not supported they are being deprecated
microsoft has pretty much killed atoms
so we encourage everyone to migrate to
vs code
and microsoft announced that they would
be killing atom in like
one year
cycle or something so
you've we've been warned so
move away from atom because it's been uh
slowly dying
so let's see one more thing where are
some cool extensions in vs code for
julia there is just one i think it's the
it's the julia formatter
and it is a nice extension
uh
and
and
it's if you are a jeweler developer you
pretty much know about this extension
and
july developers are sometimes uh
they they want the code to be formatted
in a certain way so that
you create less friction when you are
doing development so this is a nice
extension for you to format your code
let's close all of this
okay
let's
move forward let's go to our uh third
uh section here
and our next break is in 45 45 minutes
so
boolean operators
now julia we do have uh three boolean
operators like every other language
it's called
uh we do have the end
so if we do something like
true
and false
we get back false
because uh that's
if you if you go back to logic the whole
uh
truth tables you see that
true and false returns false so that's
how we use it
uh second one
is or
so if you go true
or
false that returns true
so you use the double ampersand and the
double vertical bars for and and or
respectively and we also have the
negation then not
so
if we do not true we get back false
so that's how we do boolean statement in
julia
the end is double n percent the r is
double vertical bars
and the not is a bank it's pretty much
similar to other languages
there is just
one caveat
why
we are using
double and percent and not
single
and percent what is the difference
well the difference is that uh
if you go to the julia documentation and
you take a look and help function for
the end
double the end the double n percent
you see that this is um
this is a short secret boolean and so
this is a boolean operator
and if you go into the
a single
and percent
this is the
uh bitwise and
so
uh the single uh n percent or single
vertical bars they are um
bitwise operators
so you will you would use that in not
a boolean comparison you would use that
in a bitwise operation so
i don't recommend you using that only if
you know what you are doing uh most of
the time
of the time in your julia day-to-day
uh
scripting and
and doing uh stuff in julia you pretty
much will be using the
and and or operators the double and
percent and the double vertical bars so
that's the difference
and that's and sometimes that can
confuse folks so
single and percent in single vertical
bar is the bitwise operator
and this is probably not what we are
looking for
when we want to do
uh
boolean comparisons in julia
the video will be
uh it's been uh recorded and if you need
to leave the live stream you can watch
it later
but you will miss the whole into
interactivity and asking questions but
the the session is being recorded for
later view
let me see if we have questions i don't
think so let's move forward then
numerical comparison
that is pretty much
the same as in other languages so we
have the equality and inequality so i
can do something like 5 equals 5 and i
get a true statement i can do 5 is
different than 5 and i get a false
statement
and that also uh works across type so if
i do five equals five point zero which
is the float
uh
oh sorry let's do equals
yeah we get true so pretty much uh in
those comparisons
julia will do an implicit conversion to
compare those types
uh not not conversion it will account
that you are using different types and
it will
either promote one of those
and it will make a fair comparison
so that's how we do uh
numerical comparisons we can do equality
and inequality
so five double equals it's equality
and
five not equal is inequality
so that's how
we do it in julian
and also we do have the less than
and less than or equal to
so we can do it something like
five less than six and this is true
we can do also five less or equal than 5
that's true also
and we can also do
latex so if you want latex
the latex symbol for
[Music]
lower or equal is l e so we can do
backslash l e auto complete that and as
you can see we have a nice
um
less
than or equal to
latex unicode symbol and this also works
most people
don't like this they prefer more
more default stuff
but you can do that if you want to
and the same with a greater than
so we can do 10 greater than 2 and this
is true and we can also do greater than
or equal to which is
the greater followed by the equal
statement
and this is um
this is also true and also the latex
command for greater or equal to is g e
so we can do g e
and this is our greater or equal to then
greater than or equal to and this is
this also is possible in julia so that's
how we do our numerical comparisons uh
we can pretty much mix and match those
so we can do something like
10
less than two
and
five
more than two or
uh five
more than two and i don't know what this
will spill out because i pretty much
type it random stuff
so this is true
and also let me copy this whole line and
paste it here we can also do the
negation of
everything
and this is false
so you can pretty much mix and match
just be careful with the parenthesis to
delineate the scope of your numerical
comparison
so uh
that's pretty much how you do numerical
comparisons and boolean operate
operations in juliet
let me see if i have questions
what is promotion julia oh
that's a tricky question so
when we are comparing different types
or when we are doing stuff that
uh
that
there isn't an explicit way to do it in
julia
julia will promote
some types or will change some types to
another type and
i definitely have not prepared to answer
this question so it's been a while since
i don't mess with promotion rules in
julia but if you go to the documentation
and
and and search for promotion you will
find
pretty much everything that you need
there so promotion is when you get a
type and you promote the type to another
type is an operation in a type so you
have a variable that's one type and you
need to do something with with that
variable
sometimes julia will promote that
variable to another type that's what we
call promotion
julian
is a boolean variable not a bit i mean
everything
translate down to bits
that's i don't know how
the boolean variable will be represented
in memory so probably
the the julia documentation will be your
best guess on finding this out
unfortunately i i don't know if boiling
variables will be a single bit or not
but everything will be translated to
bits
in in a computer
um
let's move to types
so
this this was pretty much um easy stuff
now types uh
we might get a little bit more
we might get a little bit in in some
nice stuff and
not so
naive
so um
in julian we have things called abstract
types and concrete types
uh i'm gonna share
my screen i'm gonna
share another screen so hang tight one
second
so stop screen
here again
[Music]
so
this is uh
it's a little bit outdated but i do like
this image here
because it uh
kind of gives you a brief overview of
the type systems
of the type system in julia
so everything that has a dashed dot
it's a abstract type
and i'm gonna explain in a brief what
abstract types are
everything that has a solid line it's a
concrete type
as you can see everything in julia
derives from a
single type called annie and that and
and the end type can be anything like
the name
says we can have subtypes and super
types so
any is a super type of every type in
julia so every type in julia has a has
an annie as a super type or in other uh
in in in another way is a subtype of any
abstract types
uh we cannot instantiate we cannot
create objects like variables
uh out of
uh abstract types
we can only create uh
variables or objects out of concrete
types so that's the difference between
abstract and concrete in julia
as you can see
let's let's change our attention here to
the flow types
we do have
two types of floats
we have more but but here we have two
types in this image we have two types of
floats two types of concrete
types
of flow to have float 32 and 64. and
those are float pointing
numbers with a 32-bit precision or
64-bit precision
and they are a subtype of abstract float
so abstract float represents any type of
float but it's an abstract type you
cannot
instantiate you cannot create objects of
an abstract type
but we are going to
see why they are useful in our functions
next file
so hang tight
and let's take a look at the integer so
integers we do have one abstract type
it's called
integer and we do have two subtypes they
are abstract from the integer type we do
have sign integers that
are accompanied by a sign either
positives or negatives
and we also have unsigned
integers that the abstract type it's
called unsign
and
this they have uh
here represented in 64 and into 32 bits
that's
um integer
finite integers with 64 and 32-bit
precisions
and we also have u and 64u in 32 that's
unsigned integers without a sign
with 64 or 32-bit precision so so that's
the difference between uh
abstract and concrete uh types so let me
stop sharing my screen and going back to
vs code
so if you remember we had
x equal 3.4 and y equals 22. so let's
run those two lines of code
now if i say type of x
that's a float 60 bar
if i say a type of y
that's an integer 64 bits an inch 64.
now i have some uh
i have some
functions called
super types
which uh
will get
us back
an array a vector of the super types of
certain uh type so for example
if i say super
type oh super type of load 64
oh super tight
we got back
uh pretty much uh actually not a vector
sorry a tuple and we are going to
explain those in a bit
and we see that we have float64 that's
the first one and
another super type is abstract float
after that we have a higher
in the hierarchy super type called rio
it's a real numbers and then we have
number that's any number and of course
any is the super type of all types in
july
and if we do super type without so let
me copy this if we do super type without
plural a singular
so
we get the first
super type the the in line of hierarchy
of our desired type sometimes we
we want to do something like we can do
super type and then we can do type of x
so i have no idea what x is so i can do
that
this thing inside will be evaluated to a
float 64 so if i just run this you see
that i get flow 64 and if i run this
line i get back an abstract float
so
we can do that we can also do something
like
subtypes
now step types we don't have a singular
function because
uh generally
we have more than one subtype
so subtypes of abstract
float
uh so this returns a vector
and as you can see
we have big float if you need more than
64 bits of precision you have a type
called big float
it we have 16 bits 32 bits and 64 bit
and
all of those
are
concrete types
so that's how we check um the high the
hierarchy of types in julian
we also have the nice
uh diagram that i just show it
to you
there's also a operator called isa
uh so for example our x it's three point
fourteen so if i do
x is a float 64 that's a boolean
comparison
so that will either returns true or
false so x yes it is a float 64. it is
it a float 32 no it's not
is it an abstract float
yes it is so um if you do
an object
you use the e is a operator
into any of the super types of the type
of that object you get a true statement
it will evaluate to a true statement
so of course uh we also have real
yes is a real and x is also a number
because that's the next
abstract type from um
uh abstract float
uh number uh sorry real number
and yes and
of course any type or any object is
a is a
a subtype of any so this evaluates to
true
so we can do the same with the y y is an
integer
64 so we we can do is why an n64 yes it
is is it an in 32 no it's not
is it just int int it's the abstract
type of um
all integers so it's pretty much like
our abstract float but for integers this
also evaluates to true
but y is not an abstract float
but y is a real as as you can see
uh so that's a basic overview of types
let's see if we have questions if you
have questions please
uh ask them in pigeonhole
that's where we are concentrating all of
our questions
uh
yes
sizing bytes so if i want to get a
sizing bytes you do base
the memory
size x
and of course a 6 64 bit precision float
takes
eight bytes
you will see that this is pretty much
obvious but in some languages you don't
get back an eight and
a lot of popular languages so
that's why you should switch to julia
julia is where
a 64-bit
precision float is just 8 bytes nothing
more
thanks arturu
why methods like is abstract type is
concrete type doesn't follow camel case
that's a great question so we have uh is
concrete type so that is a function
and now my uh
prover thing is working so as you can
see
vs code will pretty much say that we can
use
any type here so t
is a any type so we can say okay is
concrete type
load
64. remember the
rule of thumb
camera case
is for
modules packages and types and this is a
function
so this is pretty much a lowercase
that's why it's lowercase it's not a
mojo it's not a package and it's not a
type it's a function so it's lowercase
and we also have uh the
we also have the uh is abstract type so
if you say something like any
yes it is so this evaluates to true
that's the idea behind these two helper
functions is concrete type is abstract
type
let's cover
[Music]
something called containers in julia i
don't think i don't know if that is the
official uh technical term but i'm gonna
say it containers with double quotes
these containers they have like a curly
brackets
so if i create a vector in julia which
is analogous to python
a list
so i create a vector called one two
three four five that's a vector of
integers
from one to five and i assign this to my
x back
so as you can see
this is a five element vector
and then you get that
curly brackets
so any
any time that you say curly brackets in
julia
your spine your sense should be
triggering and say okay this is a
container this is a collection this is
something that holds elements inside
so this is not a primitive type like
like we say so that's that's the idea
behind the curly brackets so as you can
see this is a vector
and the type that the vector holds
is a vector
that holds
elements of type in 64.
so
that's
how we read these curly brackets every
time you get a curly bracket it's
uh something
saying that this is a container type and
the type of the container is the thing
inside the curly bracket curly brackets
so that's
if you do type of x back
you see that uh that the type of our x
vector is
a vector of in 64 and it's pretty much
like a shorthand annotation or an alias
or array
of certain type in 64
with number of dimensions one so if you
have a one dimensional array that means
a vector so that's why we have this nice
factor
uh notation we also have matrix so if we
do something like x
matrix i don't know if you have time to
cover matrix today
but matrix we do have a a different
syntax so i'm going to put one two three
i'm not using
uh commas here
and the next line i use a semicolon and
i do four five six so this should
translate
in a two by three matrix two rows three
columns one two three four five six
and as you can see this is a matrix of
type in 64.
and if i do type of
type of x matrix i get back
this is the matrix
so i have the curly bracket curly brac
brackets this means that this is a
container type
and the underline type inside that
container is of integer 64 in 64 and
also this thing here is an alias a short
hand notation for
array
of certain type with two with
dimensionality of two so a two
dimensional array is a matrix
so
it's a race all the way down so as as
you can see um
vector and matrix they pretty much uh
get uh compiled or or gets represented
down
as
a race of
a certain type with a certain and in
dimensionality
so we can have like 10 source if you go
over oh higher than two dimensions
pretty much it works
uh one more thing so what if i create
like a
another vector
but this vector i have one
i string
a boolean
and a float
so
this vector will be a four element
vector of any
so the underlying type of this vector is
any
and
[Music]
as as you get
uh more familiar with the julia
community and the julia
uh type of things
how we do things here we don't do that
because it's not performant
so you are going to pay a lot of
performance penalties if you leave your
vectors uh with
an
a type that is any
because tula cannot
be efficient in allocating memory and
doesn't know what to do with this
because you can pretty much
stick anything inside this vector so
having vectors of type any
will not be
the best
habit to create so always make your
vectors
a single type
if possible
and this also works with matrix so uh
that's pretty much everything about
types in julia to get you started
we get
we know
we we have abstract and concrete types
abstract types we cannot instantiate
they represent uh collections of the
they
represent a sets of concrete types
concrete types we can instantiate we can
create variables and objects
we can do super types super type and
subtypes helper functions to inspect
the types that that that we cross uh in
our julia uh
coding
so whenever you you cross paths with a
type that you've never seen before
inspect it with super types
and subtypes and you can also do is that
comparison
and is ah it's just a function so you
can do is r
y real that also works so this is a
function but you can also use this as an
operator but julia will we will pretty
much parse this and and convert this
into this function call here but you can
use that as an operator to get the size
of things you can do base dot summary
size
so this function is not exported by
default into your
current environment so you you you need
to access the base model and then the
dot
and the function because this function
is not exported
uh
you can also test if a type is concrete
or abstract
uh and we can create vectors and matrix
and any type of arrays
and whenever you see a curly bracket
you should be pretty much familiar that
this is a kind of a container and the
thing inside the curly brackets is the
underlying type of the elements of that
container so that's the idea here let me
see if we have some questions
so we have a question
i pretty much don't know how to answer
is
abstract type i don't think uh
we have that function
is abstract type
oh do we have it
no we we don't have it
uh
so
uh
the only implementation is this one here
we don't have the camo casing
implementation
uh
[Music]
what is meant by abstract array type
okay so
take a look at this uh
vector here
so x vac
if i do a type of x spec
you see that this is a vector of integer
64.
uh
so
this
is a vector
so x back is a vector type and the
underlying
elements
underline type of the elements that it
holds
is of type in 64. that's that's what we
mean
uh with container and i don't know if
the container is the technical term it's
just a
type
we call that um
positive types it's just a type that
not composite i'm sorry uh it's a type
that holds other types that's pretty
much it you cannot do that with the
primitive types like integer floats
booleans and strings
so they
they are a primitive type so so that's
what i mean with containers it's not the
most precise technical uh definition but
it's pretty much intuitive and this is
the idea in this introduction to julian
what is meant by abstract array of type
we are going to cover this in the
functions so you can pretty much uh
create a function that will operate on
an abstract array
of
a certain type like abstract
float
to
so this
uh if
if we say that in a function signature
we will
be expecting any kind of array
uh that
has any kind of floats but arrays with
dimensionality go equals true so that's
better
so that's that's what we made by
abstract array and
we have some
uh packages that extend the arrays so we
have something in in the julia
standard library to have a sparse array
so we have spice matrix we also have a
package called
static
arrays i think this is how it's not in
my environment but we have a static
arrays
uh which is a faster implementation and
all of those they will implement
subtypes of the abstract array abstract
vector and abstract matrix types
so
if you want your function or if you want
your code to function with all of the
subtypes of the
all of the different types of vectors
you can do that so that's why we have
also abstract types for the
collection types
that's that's that that's the idea
oh we do have a lot of questions
so so one
last questions before
we move forward um
okay no
okay let's let's do more questions we do
have a lot of questions so it's variable
type string the same as vector shar no
is not the same a vector in julia it's
pretty much
a collection
of objects
so if you want to create like a vector
of
of characters you can do so
with
something like this so as you can see
this is a two element vector of char
and the same if you
convert those to
strings so
if you do something like this
you get back a two element factor of
string so in some languages especially
the typed ones the compiled ones like
uh c c plus plus and rust
you get that representation that
string is um
a vector of
shards but but not
precisely here you can index a string so
you can get something like
uh my string which we already defined it
so welcome to gila cone i can get the
first element and i get the w so that's
welcome we can also index strings if
if we need but they are not the same as
vector of chars
uh its container the same as listing
python not
not exactly so in python a list you
don't have an underline type in julia if
you if you if you create a vector like
one two three four five
this vector it has a type it's an
integer 64.
and
i cannot add once i'm instantiate this
um
x so if i try to
push and we are going to showcase this
in a minute if i want to try to push
i always forget it's a push
there you go push
let's forget is first the collect so if
i want to push like to include a new
uh element in my vector x with with the
with the value six
uh it gets implicitly converted to an
integer
or if we try to do it push
a string we'll get an error
and
as you can see we get a method error i
cannot convert an object of typing
string to a type of integer because you
are trying to push to include a string
type into a vector of integer so if i
cannot convert it
it throws an error so python it doesn't
have that
and this is why julia is much faster
than python because julia asserts that
things are fast by making things what we
call type stable
but that's a little bit more advanced
topic not for today
uh types implemented as classes no types
are types julie is not an object
oriented language we don't have classes
we have structs that we probably
will cover in the last minutes of this
of this workshop so stay tuned we'll
discuss uh structs you know in a bit
is there any efficient data structure
for this in julia
almost all data structures in julia are
efficient
because julia is uh
it
it was created with efficiency and speed
in mind so
you need to make some effort to make
julia slow
but
go ahead there is a section in
performance in the
documentation take a look on on that
and there are some things that you need
to do to make sure that julia is always
top-notch in performance while executing
your code
okay i don't see any more questions in
pigeonholes so
let's move forward once more
uh so we are going to start now with the
uh
if else if and else this is the control
flow statements as they are known in
other languages and also julia they are
called control flow
so
in python for example you have something
like if
uh
something
and then you you have the column and you
need the indentation
so
that's how you're doing python in julia
uh
it's the if
and
as you can see there is a tooltip in vs
code and if i click or select this
tooltip it will auto complete the if
statement for me
so we pretty much put if and then the
expression that we want to be evaluate
this expression needs to return a
boolean so it needs to be validated as
either true or false
so if i say something like
let's say
if
5
greater than 2
then i go i go to the next thing
let's say print line
5 greater than 2.
as you can see julia
we have the if statement and all of
those special statements that i'm that
i'm going to start uh presenting now the
if the if else if the for loops the
while loops the functions
uh they need to be followed by an end
statement
so
if i start with the if statement i need
to
end with the end statement
so this pretty much will evaluate and
this
thing will evaluate to true so it will
execute this code here otherwise it
won't so
if i
switch
say if 5 less than 2 so that will
evaluate to false we get nothing
so nothing is printed
and julia is not sensitive to
indentation it's just that a convention
for you to indent your uh if and and
other blocks whatever you see an end a
block that that that starts with a
keyword argument and has an end
keyword argument
to
to tell julia that the statement has
ended
uh you will indent by either two or four
spaces depending on which you prefer
most of the time is for space but julia
is
it doesn't it i mean uh
it's not sensitive to indentations so if
i pretty much uh
un
indent so if i remove the four spaces
from my if statement and i run this it
works
but
to make it uh easier for the eyes and
and for us to to see the code we
generally uh indent by four bases that's
how we do it but uh julia doesn't need
that it needs the end here so the end
here if i remove this end
we get an error
so
incomplete syntax so we get um
we get a premature or end of input
so that's what we get when we don't put
the end statement
so that's a single week
we can have a
an else so we can do if
uh
five
higher than two
let me copy this as i said i'm lazy so
print line else
print
five is
lower than
are we equal
to something like this
so as you can see uh
for the
if
and uh if else statements we just need
one and keyword we don't need to
so we pretty much put the if
and then we add the else and we end it
with the end keyword
so this expression here will be
evaluated if true it will run this code
otherwise it will run this code here so
this will pretty much print the first
the line 10 so
5 is greater than 2 now if we change
signs it will print the thing inside
it will evaluate the code inside the end
the else block
oops
and
there you go we get it evaluated
so that's how we chain if with an else
statement
we also have uh if
else if
and else so in python you would have
something like if
uh
something that you indent then you do
ali
other thing you indent and then you do
it uh else
and you would indent your expression in
julia uh you pretty much do an if
so let's say um
let's
copy
let's
make a variable okay x
so x equals five so
if x
is higher than two we are going to print
line
uh
x
uh your
potential
uh
elf if
x
lower than two
we are going to print line
uh
x
lower
than
two
and we put an else statement
uh in line so it's if it's not higher or
lower it's equal so x is
equal to 2 and then we end with the end
statement so we can pretty much change
how how many else ifs
so i can do something like else if
x equals zero
x is equal to zero
and i can pretty much change how many uh
else if statements i want they just need
to be sandwiched between the if and the
else
so let's run the first line of code to
assign our variable x with the value
five
then we run this as and as you can see x
is higher than two
and if we change this to two we get x
is
look x is equal to 2 because
then it evaluated all of those e's if
and else if all of those were evaluated
to false
hence the only thing that that was left
is print to execute the code in the else
block so that's how we do if else if
statements in julia it's pretty much uh
easy and and very familiar to other
languages
so that's something easy now let's do uh
we have some questions
and before i answer the questions i have
some
exercise for you to do it in the five
minute break
and
let's answer there is one new questions
why isn't else if shortened to elite in
python because
uh
it's a design choice
i prefer else if because elite
um
it's a little bit
ambiguous so i prefer else if
that's my personal opinion but
as
former simpson would say it was already
this when i arrived so it was like this
when i arrived so it was a design choice
uh long before my julia days so
that's how the language was was made
uh okay so let's go into a five minute
break we'll be back in five minutes and
there is some nice exercise here for you
if you want to try it on
um
so we have two exercises they are in the
github ripple
there are some solutions also
but
if you want to to if you are stuck you
can see the solutions
but try to make those exercises and see
you guys in five minutes
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay and we are back
uh let's
wait for
everyone to get back
uh i think we are done with our five
minute break
sorry about that
let me see if you have more questions no
we don't
uh so um let me showcase how i would
solve this uh
exercise just a caveat exercise it's
like a mountain you want to go to the
top there is not only a single way there
are multiple ways so the way that i'm
solving
might not be the only way or the most
efficient way but it's a way to the top
so
um
we we get a number so this number i
already
asked julia to generate a random number
between one and a hundred
um
and it's nine so let's test if a number
is a multiple of three five or seven
how i would do it is uh i would use the
modulus operator in julia so if number
mod
3 is equal to 0 that means that
if i divided
this number by 3
if i get back
uh if the remainder is zero that is
pretty much what is testing it's uh
the modulus of operator that you see a
lot in algebra
so if number
is um
modulus 3 equals 0 this will evaluate to
a true statement or false
so that's the most important thing in an
if else if and else block you need your
statements to be evaluated to either
true or false so if number modulus 3
mod 3 is equal to 0 that means that the
number is divisible by 3. so the
number is divisible by three
and we pretty much chain an lc so s else
if a number
modulus mod five equals zero
i'm going to copy this line here this
mean that the number is divisible by
five
and we put another else if number
mod seven equals
zero uh
that means that our number is divisible
by seven
else
just print
that
the number is not
divisible by
three five or seven there you go
and of course we need to
uh
of course we need to end it with the end
statement let me just close the door one
second
okay
and if we run
this
block of code here
oh if we want all of this
uh we get back
uh
we get back that the number is not
divisible because i
asked it to generate another number so
let me see 69.
so let's run this uh yeah 69 is
divisible by 3. so
that's how i do it second exercise
oh this is nice so this is a geometry
question
we have the cartesian plane
and we have the quadrants of the plane
so we have the quadrant one
that's pretty much uh if if the points
are positive so we can do something like
this so here i'm i'm generating uh two
random numbers between
minus one
point zero
and one
point zero
with step size of zero one so this will
generate everything from
uh minus one point zero minus zero point
nine zero point eight
so on until one
so that's how we
we do intervals in julian
how that's how we do it it's much more
intuitive than python
uh i i think
uh
i'm always adding plus
my python scripts because i don't know
how to do zero index
so this will generate two random numbers
and i'm going to unpack those numbers
into x and y
because this will generate uh
two numbers and i'm going to assign
those to x and y
so there you go we have 0.5
oh sorry i need to remove the the break
yes
uh
oops
there you go
thank you
yeah i forgot that
uh thank you thank you for uh letting
letting me know so
here how we do it so if x is higher than
zero
and that's a boolean statement and
y
is higher than zero that means that both
of them are positive and the point is in
the first quadrant credent of the
cartesian plane so i'm gonna print
line
uh x and y are in the first pattern of
the cartesian
plane there you go
gonna copy this line
and else if so if x
is less than zero so if x is negative
and
y
is uh positive that means
that our
point is in the second pattern
now we are going to do another else if x
is
uh negative and
y is positive
oops y is negative
oh
then we are in the third
else if
or you can do just an else but
no no you're gonna do an else
because there's a corner case so we we
do else if x
is less than
x is higher than zero and
y
is less than zero
uh it's on the fourth
round else okay if
our point is in any of those
uh then of course our
uh
are
at the origin so it's zero zero the
point
so that's how we do it and as you can
see it's in the fourth quadrant of the
cartesian plane that's that's the idea
here
so let's move to the
for loops in julian
so let's save this
uh
there we go so how do we do a for
looping julian it's pretty much the same
as in
as in uh if
we we start with the keyword argument
four and when we type this vs code
already uh
does uh nice
two tip for us so
four
and it pretty much auto completes for us
so for something in
an iterable so something that you can
iterate so we can do
i or or number in um
let's do one two three four five
so for
every number in one two three four five
you can do something like
print our number
now if we execute this
we get uh
back
uh
we get back
we get printed our numbers in the
collection so it's pretty much how we do
it you can also do it with intervals
that's what we call in julia so you can
do something for n in 1 to 10
you can also ask to print
and also add to print the number
so this will print all the numbers from
1 to 10
we can also do something like 1
2
10 so this will increase the step size
to 2
so we can do 1 3 5 7 9 the next one
would be 11 but 11
is
is greater than our upper bound of 10
so that's why we don't get an 11 back
here
and
uh
yes i forgot uh something about this
exercise about the axis
yes uh someone
actually uh
noted that yes
so
you need to fix this if else statement
to account for the cases that your
number could be in a axis
so
maybe add greater than equals
in those will fix that
and or you can do something like this
yes that's
uh at the origin of the or
at one of the x
and if it's on both of x's uh so it's
the
it's in the origin so i guess that's it
uh good point thanks for the correction
uh
so it's it's really easy how to do a for
loops in julian
you can also do something like
oh n equals
i don't know uh
oh there's one nice thing in julia is
that you can
c plus plus has that so in c plus plus
you can do something like this it's a
thousand so in julia you do underscore
so if you have like big numbers
like this
you can
pretty much do something like
four
n
in
one
every a hundred thousand until my big n
uh oops my big and you are going to
if
uh
then you can put it inside and that kind
of thing so you can do pretty much like
print line
and
oop and then you can run this for loop
and it will print
all of those of course uh we need to do
zero maybe
and this will print our
uh hundred thousand so zero a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand and so on
so we can do
uh
this kind of thing so the syntax is uh
start
tap
finish
so you do something like start at 1 the
step size is 3 and finish at 20.
so
this
will
this is the syntax
that's that's the syntax
and if you of course by default if you
do not put any step
uh it defaults by one so we will go in
increments of one
that's the idea
but for loops is pretty much uh easy in
in in julia and also uh julie is one
index set so
it's not zero index so
uh it's a little bit intuitive because
if you want to go from 1 to 220 you want
to include the 20
and you can do more stuff in intervals
go to the documentation at
julialang.docs.julylink.org
so
there you see the documentation
also
julia is we indent the for loops just
for a better visual
uh representation to make code more
readable but
we don't need to indent those we just
need to have the and statement here so
one two three four five
i left some exercise here uh
i'm gonna leave you guys to do it in the
next
break
and maybe we'll cover those if we have
time
i need to cover
more steps so i i won't be doing those
exercises because we are running out of
time a little bit
let me see if we have questions we have
questions
do julia use parentheses yes we do
so
is this font size better
so the rand syntax uh
it's uh a little bit
it's not simple because it's a function
that you can you can call it with
different arguments that's what they
call multiple multiple dispatch it's one
of the main features of julia so as you
can see there is 160
ways that i can call rand
and we are going to cover multiple
dispatch in
uh a bit
and i will
showcase the rent for you okay
uh what is the difference between print
line and print line
light print print and print line print
ln
so oscar pretty much already uh replied
for me thank you oscar so print line
puts a new line after the thing that is
printed uh and print does not so for
example let me showcase that with the
this for loop here if i do print you see
i get one two three four
i get 20. so i pretty much i'm printing
stuff in the terminal without adding a
new line
so print line is the same
so
if i do something like
this
oh now i get big line i'm pretty much
doing string interpolation here
pretty much like an f string in python
and i'm adding the new line uh character
here so this um it's what print line is
doing so
green line will print
every time that it prints it will add a
new line
so that's that's how print line is doing
[Music]
can you comment on the speed of the for
loops in julia compared to those in
python c plus plus python is faster and
depending on your
code it can be faster than c plus plus
the painting um
there is a nice case study of some
algorithms that
are colleague
at the
institute of spatial
research here in brazil he was trying to
translate some julie stuff into c plus
plus and with the help of the community
he benchmarked it and julia
algorithms was
were faster than the c plus plus and
those were very
uh some of some of those had a lot of
for loops
but
faster than python yes definitely uh
presidency plus plus could be depending
on
the context
because
julia uses llvm
to do a
intermediate representation of your code
and it exposes that to the compiler and
the compiler in some cases can optimize
better the code even when comparing to c
plus plus
optimize code
so i'll leave that to the compiler guys
and the speed guys so take a look at the
conference
schedule and go to those workshops those
talks that you see a lot about
compiler and performance in julia
how long does it take to learn julia for
basic operations
uh
a little bit i mean this workshop is
already covering like i i mean like
almost
everything that you need to know to get
started with julia
for you to migrate fully just a little
bit and you are ready to go
so let's move on
let's go to our
while loop so this is going to be a
really brief one while loop it's pretty
much the same as you saw in the if and
the for loops
so you pretty much
put something like okay let's define an
n here 10
so
this is what i'm doing don't do it
because it's not performant but i'm
gonna do it just for the sake of showing
you guys
so
y o n less than
let's do n equals one so while n less
than five we are going to print line n
and you are going to
increment n by one this is not
performant because n is outside the
scope of the while loop so it's in the
global scope and using global variables
is not good but just to showcase you
guys
so as you can see
it keeps repeating this slope
uh until the condition is turned false
so every time it goes here
it will
every time it goes here uh it will
uh evaluate this if it's true it will
execute this code block if it's not true
it will carry on so that's how
uh
while loops works in julia
we do have some exercise here
uh print all natural numbers from from 1
to n
and
print all natural numbers from 1 to n in
reverse
and also print all natural numbers from
1 to n
even numbers from 1 to n
so pretty much
those exercises starts with a random
number called n that is between 10 and
50. just just to get uh how would you
put n in the loop to avoid the global
variable that's a good question uh
you could do some things but in julia
one point
i think 1.8 or 1.9 in in the next or the
the following
uh julia release you could annotate your
global variables you could say something
okay this is an inch 64.
you could do this
but as you can see there is a an error
here type declarations on global
variables are not yet supported they
will be
uh but they are not yet supported you
can use a function that's yeah that's
pretty much it you put inside a function
and there you go
and type globals are in 1.8 that's it so
pretty much we are already in the
release candidate 3 so 1.8 release
candidate number 3 so 1.8 might be just
around the corner right after julia cone
i don't know
i'm not a julia developer but
might be
okay
but that's how you would solve it
and thanks oscar
so um that's how we do while loops
um
let's see questions
we don't have any questions
okay let's move to the functions then
and this is where we are going to spend
a little time
because this is uh julia is
is a language that uses heavily
functions
and we are going to showcase some
multiple dispatch
examples here
so functions how we define a function in
julia
is pretty much
the same as we did in the for loops the
while loops we start with a keyword
argument that's function
we say the function name
we open and close back brackets any
arguments that the function takes will
be inside those arguments
and
here we do stuff inside the function
so this is the body of the function as
it's it's called
inside the function
so
this is the body of the function
and we end with the end statement so
that's how we define a function
and there you go we have a function it's
already defined
and if we go here to our julia
extension
and you go down here
you see that
we have a function name here in our wix
workspace so
you see that we have a function name
here
it's our in our workspace and we can
close this thing here and you see that
function was defined it's a generic
function
with one method and we we will uh
get back to this method and functions
uh this distinction in a bit
uh but that's how we we define functions
and if we call this function
it pretty much returns nothing because
by default if we don't do anything the
function will return nothing
there is a
so if we do uh
type of
the return of the function when we call
the function it's nothing
so that's pretty much what the function
returns
so
this is the
this is the
long form the default the default form
but we also have the short form
we can do something like
short function
equals nothing
so we can also define a function like
this
so sometimes you see this in july
scripts when when the function is very
short that
to make function
the function name the arguments and then
everything and then the end it's
cumbersome uh developers will switch to
the short form assignment
so and if we go into the short function
it returns nothing and if we don't type
of
short function it's nothing
so we can also do something like short
function returns uh
i don't know returns a
short function so we can also do this
and if we call the short function we get
back a string
so that's um
that's like like compact from assignment
uh
we do have some uh
things in in the chat
no that's not a lambda lambda is an
anonymous function we are going to cover
this in a bit
uh this is just a compact function
assignment but this if i do type of
short function it exists
uh it's uh
it exists and it's uh
it's a single to type so it exists
anonymous functions it's just reference
i'm gonna cover anonymous functions in
in a bit
but this is just a function
defined using the short
form assignment
so let's start um
so
um
we also
can do something like function
so
function name
and then we can say so return
function
and then we can end in julia we
generally use the return statements
uh to indicate that our function is done
and we want to return
we want to return
whatever value we want to return so this
could be either
a string like i'm doing here or we can
do something like
x
equals function and we can do return x
so this also works so if i if i call
function name
we get back a string called function
so that's how
we
make
we
assign functions in juliet that's how we
do it
as always uh we just
indent the functions the the keyword
arguments that that needs to be followed
by an end statement we indent those with
uh four spaces but you don't need that
because julia is not sensitive to
indentation it's just for us humans to
understand and read the code better
but this also works and
functions
okay
but but
by convenience we indent
our blocks inside a keyword argument
that needs to be followed by an end
and a keyword
now let's cover um let's see if i have
questions in the
pigeonhole
no my short function is not a lambda we
already covered that thanks for the for
the question
so positional arguments versus keyword
arguments so in julia we have position
arguments and we have keyword arguments
like every other language
but we have a distinction between those
so let's create a new function so this
is a function
let's call function1 and this takes an x
and a y and it returns so let's do
some two numbers
there you go
return x plus y and then end
so if you call if we run this
and
we
call
sum
two numbers with three and four we get
back a seven
so this function it takes two positional
arguments
that's the idea now um
let's add keyword arguments so i'm going
to
create a new function called sum
two numbers
with
caveats
it's going to take x and y as positional
arguments but
i'm going to add a semicolon this
semicolon states to julia okay julia i'm
done with positional arguments
i'm going to
start my keyword arguments from now on
so there are two position arguments and
now i'm going to start with the keyword
arguments i'm going to start with the
keyword argument one
this has a default value
of
let's do one and also i'm gonna start
with the keyword two
and this has a default value of two and
this is going to return the sum
the sum of x y
q one the word argument one keyword
argument two and end
so if i do some two numbers with caveats
and i pass in four and three
we will probably get back a ten
oops
oh i need to convert those
[Music]
to okay
uh it's been a while since
so it's a vector okay so let's do
a vector here
there you go
now it returns a 10.
uh don't be scared about errors as you
see i get tons of errors
so as you can see uh
i just provided the two position
arguments and by and if i do not specify
the keyword arguments they will take on
the default values
now if i just try to run this function
with one keyword argument you see that i
got this
blue squiggle line
it's saying to me that there's a method
called
so
there is no method
let's
there is no method matching
this function which takes integer 64.
the closed candidates are
some that takes two positional arguments
and two keyword arguments
and it's defined at
in this
file here line 25
so that's the whole stack trace
of course uh the positional argument
i need to
the ordering matters but the keyword
arguments that ordering doesn't matter
so key 2 equals 10
and p1 equals 5
this is going to turn out 22. this will
work because the position arguments i
can specify in any ordering that i want
so that's how that's the difference
between a
keyword argument and positional
arguments
uh keyword documents can be anything
so
i'm going to explain this a little bit
i'm going to
let's say i have a
function
this function is called round number
and it takes an x
now i'm going to give
the type to that x so this x is a float
64
and this returns round off x
so that's it so that's my round number
it takes only one position argument and
this position argument is of a type
float 64.
if i call round number
in 3.14 for example a float it will
round to the nearest integer and that is
three
and we can also do
uh
in 64 of these one thing so
then um
there we go it rounds that to
uh it rounds and convert that to an
integer 64.
now what happens if i try to call this
with an integer with 3
i get an error
i get a method error
there is no method no function signature
round number that takes a positional
argument as integer
the closest candidate
is round number that takes one position
argument as float and it's defined in
this
file here line 34.
so that's what the stack trace is
telling me
so if you want you can define
a custom behavior
so let's define a function round number
that takes an
x
as um
integer 64 and just returns x because
it's a no
so
now i get a function
uh
round number
it is a generic function it now
it now has it now has two methods
uh we have the round number that takes
one position argument as float and one
position argument as integer both of
them being 64 bits
so
that's
a single dispatch
so this is custom behavior
base it in
one
type
based on the type of one argument
and this i think c plus plus can do it
and other languages can also do it
but we have something called
uh
multiple dispatch
so multiple dispatch is something that
is
i don't know if it's unique to julia but
it's pretty much uh
uh
something that julia is notorious is
known for
multiple dispatch is you you define
custom behavior
based on two
or more
argument types so for example if you are
doing machine learning
you can
have a custom training loop
and you and you can have a train
function that gets called
uh
that does custom behavior depending on
the type of arguments that you are
calling it
so this is something really powerful
and
this
couple with what we are going to be
covering in the next half hour which are
structs
is what makes julia so powerful
and
what makes julia
expressive and also
composable so you can compose different
packages with uh
with each other and things works and
and and they work uh pretty much fast
and flawlessly you don't have to create
like
apis for everything so for example in
pytorch if the thing doesn't exist in
the world of by torch by torch doesn't
know how how to deal with that
and if you go to flux
uh which is the julia
deep learning uh
stack or package
uh you can pretty much create new stuff
without
much effort just because you have
multiple dispatch
so
let me answer some questions am i going
to give some examples of multiple
dispatch
uh
okay let me see we have three questions
can you supply a value of the
experimenter by name treating the
position argument as a keyword argument
no position arguments are positional
arguments keyword arguments are keyword
argument
so
um
you pretty much have to put the keyword
arguments before
up sorry after the positional arguments
you can do it with a comma here
but i prefer to
be a little bit more ripples and
explicit and use a keyword argument as
most of the julia users like that
because this clearly states that we are
done
with uh
positional arguments and
we are
now starting with keyword arguments uh
when you call the function so this works
but if you if you try to define so let
me copy this
so i'm going to call this function a
function sum to number with caveats
number two okay because i want that to
be another function so if i do it if i
remove the
uh semicolon
uh pretty much i'm telling julia that
this function
it has
four position arguments
because there is no
semicolon and the
third and fourth position arguments they
have custom values so if the user do not
specify those the custom values will be
there so
if i define this
and if i call this
uh
like this
uh it works but if we call this like
this oh sorry
this shouldn't work let me see
there you go
uh
there you go so uh those positional
arguments
uh
they are not keyword arguments so we
we we cannot do keyword argument equals
that
uh we can only do this
because there are position arguments
or we can do maybe this
or we can do maybe this
but we cannot do it keyword arguments so
that's the difference between them
i think that answer your question
let me see
uh
other questions
does julia have up optional position
arguments and required position keyword
arguments
yes it does if you don't specify a value
it's required so if i do
let me do a function with caveats number
three okay let me do number three so
if i do something like
uh
q1 and q2
so q1 doesn't have a default value so
it's it's required a q2 has a default
value so it's not required is optional
now if i do this
uh
and
i call
uh
with just the positional arguments
i get an error
because
i need to
define q1 the keyword argument so i need
to
do key one oops
i need to do a
d1
equals three now this works
and you can do the same with it with the
position arguments any of the positional
or keyword arguments if they don't have
an equal sign that means that they don't
have a default value and they are
required
for the function to be called
uh
is there a hierarchy which function is
used when there is a multiple dispatch
case
yes there is a hierarchy um
uh
it will use the closest one so if you
have something like okay uh let's play
around okay so i have function fun one
and this function
uh takes an
abstract float okay
this will return uh
abstract
float
and
and we get a function fun one also that
takes
uh float float64
this will return a float 64 end
so
if we run this
we get that our fun one is a generic
function with two methods and if we call
this with a 2.0 we get back float64 if
we convert this 2.0 to a float 32
uh we get back
an abstract float
so that's that's the idea
so by default it will
match with the
most similar
so
since we don't have a float32 custom
function custom method for the fun one
it will default
in the abstract float
so
that's that's the idea how to specify
all the keyword arguments oh that's easy
uh
so let's go down here
so function
with
keyword arguments
only
q1 equal 1 q2 equals 2 and then return
one plus
two and i need to
take this one
and let's do another
and
so there you go and if we
draw our work only function
it works that's that's how you do it
that's easy
you have zero position arguments then
you put a semicolon okay i'm done
position arguments there are none
now we are going to supply you with the
keyword arguments that's that's that's
the idea
i think i answered all of the questions
in pigeonhole
so let's give an example of multiple
dispatch
um
oh boy i'm i'm a little bit tried with
examples so uh let's do a very simple
one
let's do
some two numbers so if you have x as
any integer
and y
as any abstract float
this will
return
x plus round
in 64
or just i think int can i do it
maybe
in y
oh
this let me let me try this so
some two numbers so let's do one and 2.0
yeah it works
it will
by default it will default to my system
so
uh it's 64 bit so i'm running julia in a
linux 64 bits
now we can do function
some two numbers
which take x position arguments it's a
abstract float so any float
and
y is an integer so this will return
x plus
let's do float lowercase
y
and end
so now if we do it the opposite way
we get three
so
that's that's
a basic example of multiple dispatch
very basic example
and this is much more powerful if we
start to create like custom user defined
types that we are going to see in the
next part
uh
i think i should have made a break
but
what about we go a little bit because
i'm worried about
the time here we have only 25 minutes
and maybe we can end like two minutes
earlier
let's see if we have any questions no
so this is a basic example of multiple
dispatch so
we have a function it's one function it
has
it has uh
three methods by default julia defines
a method with
any for us
if we define an express and
specialized version of the function so
it's a function with three function
signatures that that that does custom
behavior based it on two or more
types of arguments that's being supplied
uh that's the idea let's go over
anonymous functions so how do i do
anonymous functions anonymous function
in julia it's pretty much like you're
doing math so x x maps to x plus one
that's
sorry about that that's an anonymous
function
now if we call if we make this
uh
in parenthesis if if we wrap this
anonymous function in parenthesis
we get back a generic function that's
our anonymous function
and we can pretty much call this as a
function in the number five so that
returns a six
so that's our anonymous function uh we
can also do stuff like x
so
is odd
x
so this is the test if x is odd and i
call this in the number five this
returns true
so this is an anonymous function and we
use this function when we are doing
filtering for example so suppose i have
a filter
so filter then i get a function
this can be an anonymous function so i
can do something like
x
x
higher than three
and the second argument of the filter
function is the collection or a vector
of numbers so i can do one two three
four five six seven eight oh i already
taught you guys intervals okay so let's
do intervals easier one to ten so then
we get back a seven element vector
so that's how we use it
here
we put an anonymous function here we can
also do the same with
a function so we can say something like
it's odd
so this function i don't need to call it
in an anonymous fashion because it only
takes one position argument so i can
pretty much put the function here julia
will know how to do it
there you go
or if you want you can also make this um
uh is odd x though it's also the same
and as someone just uh noticed yeah this
is much more messy so if you like
math textbooks notation this is much
better than the lambda x or the function
x
that you have in r in python i think
it's much more intuitive
so julia is like i said in the in the
beginning my opinion julia is uh
one of the best or the best the best
scientific programming language
in
currently so
if you're doing scientific programming
you probably are a meffy person or a
science person so
you do enjoy this kind of notation you
do enjoy having
the pie
constant
in unicode for you
so
that's one thing let me see if you have
questions no questions so that's how you
do an anonymous function
i have some function exercise here for
you guys
uh
so you can play around it's in the
github repo
there are some solutions as i said my
solution might be not the best or the
most efficient one
but it's the most uh beginner friendly
solution for you
so
any questions about functions and we can
move to the last topic which is
user define
user defined types that's instructs
in julian
okay we have one question pigeonhole can
you repost the code repository yes
so it's this one
uh
there you go
actually
i posted the whole thing sorry about
that i posted
uh a link to a file
uh but it's in that repo
uh
so let's talk about um
let's talk about uh custom defined
uh user defined types so julia is not an
objective oriented
oriented language is not oop
it's a language that
it's hard to
describe with one word but it's a
language that you don't have classes
that's that's easy
to define like this
so
we do have user defined types these are
called structs and
they have that name because they are
structures and those familiar with c or
c plus plus you know what struct
instructs are i think they are in other
languages also
uh
so how we define a struct we call the
struct keyword
and we call the name of the struct so
this is a type so i'm gonna use a title
case so i'm gonna call this my struct
and as every
uh
thing in julia that i'm using a keyword
argument i need to end with the end
statement and inside the struct i list
what we called fields
so things that are inside the struct so
let's say here name
and age for example
so this is my struct
and it has two fields
uh so name and age
so if i want to instantiate a struct i
pretty much
uh put my struct so let me instantiate
myself so do that
so i am oh let's call this a person it's
better so let's go this is strict person
so
just that is a person now i need to use
a constructor
i'm not gonna cover a custom
constructors you can do that inside your
struct i'm going to just cover the
default constructor by default julia
creates for us a constructor of this
struct of this user defined type and
it's pretty much a function name with
the same
name
in title case also as the struct so it's
a person open and close brackets
and
uh
we need to pass the fields as position
arguments so the first
it's uh name so it's uh jose and the
second is age so it's 34.
yeah 34. so that's it and as you can see
we have our
dr jose here it's it's if we do type off
uh jose you see that it's a person
type
and also we can access
uh the fields
if we if we hit
joset dot
you see that vs code is suggesting us
that we can access any of the two fields
age or name so if we do choose that dot
h it will return an integer that's my
age if we do it shows that dot name it
will return a string my first name
also
uh by default
these structs they have fields which i
can query with the fill
[Music]
build fields function
so if i it it accepts i struck so if i
do my so person
uh
field
oh it's field name sorry about that
field names i got back the field names i
get back as a symbol
that's this column thing so we have name
and age
that's my field names
uh
i can also have
field types
so
let's copy this
i can also have fill types
and
as you can see
if i don't uh give a type to the fields
by default they will have type any how
do i fix that pretty much like i did in
julia in in functions i use the double
semicolon to annotate not annotate
because
it's much more than annotate because
python you can annotate but it's pretty
much like iou it's okay i promise that
this will be a type but in julia it will
error so uh if you if you annotate a
type inside a struct or a function
uh
pretty much
it will error if the type cannot be
converted to the type that you you you
set that the field or argument is
so i can put here okay name
it's a string
and age it's an integer 64. so let's
redefine our struct
oh invalid redefinition i forgot about
that so let's keep our session and let's
start a new one
so now we will work
uh
and there you go we run
and if we do uh
as you can see uh we get back it works
but if i do jose with i don't know true
a boolean type as the first position
which is the name
in our constructor
this will give an error
so
cannot convert an object of type boo to
a string
so
pretty much the stack trace tells us
that
the constructor for the person takes two
position arguments name and age and name
uh
you you call name with the boolean and
you called age with a string so that's
pretty much it we cannot convert
uh boolean to a string
if you take a look at the person
structure
uh you see that it's instruct and it has
those fields so julia
automatically generates a help
documentation
for our
user-defined types that are struct
so as you can see we have our fields and
name has to be a string and h has to be
an integer otherwise it will not
instantiate your object of type person
so
that's one nice thing about julia and we
can also see the field names as you see
its age and person but now the field
types
it's a string and integer 64.
so let me see if i have questions no
questions
uh
so that's how we define structs
uh
one thing that
one caveat with structs is that they are
immutable by default so julia is
a performance oriented language so
almost
all things will be immutable by default
so instructs are immutable by default so
if you try to
for example if you
try to get a jose name
equals i don't know you put something
with with
my uh real name which has this
funky e
because it's portuguese
you see that you get an error and the
error is
it's because julia calls the set field
bank function
and
under the hood when you are trying to
redefine a field you are trying to do
the set field a multiple struct of type
person cannot be changed so
if you create a struct
it's immutable by default
you can have mutable structs though
bear in mind that multiple
multiple structs
they are not as performant as in
multiple structs you get a
small performance hit
but if you need to change
field values
in your structs once they are
instantiated you definitely need a
mutable struct so the way you do it it's
pretty easy you do multiple is
struct
so let's do multiple person this is a
new struct
and it's going to have also name
it's a string and age it's an integer
64.
now
i can instantiate shazam mutable
it's a mutable person
my name is
and
my
age is 34.
and if i need to change something i can
do it so
the mutable name
equals so let's correct this to the
portuguese is this
and if i do just a
uh
if i type it right okay she's immutable
you see that it's a mutable person with
these two fields
do that now change it and my age i can
also change
uh my age so the whole struct is
mutable
so
oops 34
there we go
and now let's let's add 135
and as you can see jose now
has a birthday and he's 35.
uh let's see questions
uh examples of practical used for strict
yes i'm gonna give you an example it's
one of my favorites
uh it's from julia cohn i think
2018 or 19 from stefan kapinski
i don't think i'll have time to to give
the whole example but i can kind of do
it
uh i'm not using too many extensions
this is the basic default uh dark theme
and julia i'm just using the dual
extension the other
digital format that i haven't even
called yet the other ones are just other
extensions so
uh to get this you just need julia and
dark team for vs code that's it julia
does
all that
so
we can also have abstract types we can
define abstract types in julian
the way we do it is
the way we do it
so florian just asked can a structure
contain a function
no
the only function that you can have in
this struct is a custom constructor
that you find in the julia length
documentation
but
if you want a function you pretty much
define a function that takes your
okay let's see uh
function
uh newborn
dysfunction newborn so let's move over
it takes an x that's a person that's
actually a mutable person
and it pretty much uh does x so this is
a function that will alter
our struct so i'm gonna add a bank
there's a notation in julia that
convention julia that that functions
that change
one or more of its arguments
must have a bank
prepended in the name
so
uh i pretty much do x
h
equals zero so this function makes a
mutable person becomes a newborn so
i i define this function and i can do
newborn
in uh jose
and
oh hey jose issues immutable sorry about
that and now as you can see
uh
it is immutable is a baby it has zero sh
so
that's that's how you do it functions in
that that operates on your
custom user-defined types the structs
that's how you do it
now one last thing i have five minutes
so it's abstract types so we can define
abstract types we cannot instantiate
abstract types so we can do something
like
abstract
type
pet
and
so we created an abstract type pet and
now we can create choose two structs you
can do instruct
let's do doc
and we are going to use this
uh thing here
i think it's this i always forget this
yeah
so what this is is this subtype operator
so i'm defining a struct that is a
subtype of something
and i'm defining a structured dog
that is a subtype of pet
and and so there you go no fields and
i'm gonna define a struct called cat
subtype of path and end
now i can create a function
called encounter
if i have two paths x and y
this returns um
i don't know fallback okay
because it's just on the abstract type
now i can create also a new function
called function and calm
[Music]
come on okay encounter
now if a dog
encounters a
cat
return
ho ho
there's a chase
now i create a new one function
encounter x
a cat encounters a
dog
we return
oh
there is ceasing
there you go
and
then we can instantiate our rex it's our
dog
and
i don't know
meow it's our cat
so if i have encounter
if rex encounter meow
oh there's a chase
now if there is the opposite
if meow encounters uh
rex
oh there is a hissin
that's how we do it and suppose we have
like a giraffe
so and it's a sub type of bat
and then you have like uh
encounter racks and then you instantiate
the giraffe
i don't know let's call uh
i don't know a nice name for giraffe
let's call him uh
god priet
okay so godfreed is a giraffe
and
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay so i think
i think i'm back
okay sorry about that uh there was a
small issue here in my internet
so
um
sorry about that uh i'm back
uh
almost
yes i'm back thank you uh
so
where did i miss you guys
so um
we define an abstract type pet
then we define structs called dogs and
cats that are subtypes of pet and we
define a function that is
an abstract function that's a fallback
encounter between two pets that's the
abstract type and we define custom
behavior if either a dog meets a cat or
a cat meets a dog
and we also define a
struct called giraffe and we define a
thai
object called
godfred which is a giraffe and whenever
we call
hex encounters god creed there is the
fallback so
that's that's that's it
uh
so that was a basic introduction to
julia
let me just see if i have any questions
and let me stop
let me go back to them
here
so
thanks for attending uh i hope you guys
have a great juliacon we are really
excited there is a lot of great
workshops there are a lot of lighting
talks a lot of panels a lot of keynote
speakers
so don't miss our juliacon with starting
to uh today go to the
uh
conference schedule and don't miss
the workshops during this week and the
talks next week
so that's it folks thank you
and we are going to end the broadcast
now
bye